vueltos en sábanas y sacados de lo que
fue su hogar
tres miembros de una misma familia
Víctimas de los dos terremotos que han
destrozado Turquía
Este es el epicentro del segundo sismo y
una masiva operación de búsqueda y
rescate está en marcha
aquí bajo los escombros alguien vive
[Música]
y para los que esperan La angustia
aumenta a medida que pasan las horas
[Música]
hay una mujer ahí debajo ha estado
llorando mucho otros están con ella
incluidos niños es una gran catástrofe
no he visto nada igual en mi vida
su hermano y su mujer no pueden hacer
otra cosa que mirar
y al final de alguna manera lo sacan con
vida
[Música]
un raro momento de Alegría en un día
oscuro